on this now but life obviously it's a
source of protein I tried to cut down on
yourself but you're given a vegetarian
or vegan that means that mr. Muto it is
a source of protein yeah it is a source
of protein show them show them first
lesson I started earlier they said they
said that you should be vegan so he's
right now a personally he's saying you
should not would you like to so this is
a source of protein but once we
establish you yet
that's all supporting somewhere else
then it becomes too necessary so my
question to you is are you against
unnecessary violence unnecessary
violence yes what we define as violence
violence could be many things I say
stabbing in the throat yeah okay that
compared to the animal
sorry example for example - obviously
human beings is different for an animai
believe even human even animal should
not be treated in this area because we
know that the first person said I'm told
us the front of these people now listen
here he told us that there was a woman
who cheat a cat yeah and because of
action she was doing to hell fire her
and there was a prostitute woman who's
working past the well and there was a
dog who was about to die him very first
year
and see Pashu put it down the well but
whatever
and we and God said that the personnel
sent that in her sins were forgiven yeah
so to ask animal cruelty is very severe
so the fingers know what it is is what
we have different extremes so I believe
you you may be from another extradition
Amanda Chuck Emily this video so Jackie
you might be called from another extreme
way it is totally like Islam is balance
you're getting that even when we believe
in that we have fear and hope they both
know together so if you have too much
fear is not good if you have too much
hope it's not you mentioned sorry you
mentioned the cement torching your cats
yeah and usually I was wrong yes so why
is all wrong no that's why with white
which an animal for treason
so because it's unnecessary not oh no
it's not that like what's what's the
purpose because that we say for example
snorts snorting an animal it's not I
don't see that as violence because
there's a necessity for it there is
where if you believe it's not here you
can tell me okay up and don't get that
protein from Toddlers have any other
places if I can get it from just that
one meet it said a bunch of different
place in here okay so you can say okay
to get the same Serena I believe look
would I die without it I don't think so
yeah but for example she lets eat it
because of I don't know what the reason
that you deal to be a so an animal an
animal can die from a variety of reasons
yeah show to us to be free to be done in
a humane way and that you don't want the
animal and kick here be sawdust that's
ridiculous yeah and that's her ominous
now the adversaries a while when you
search an animal in east and you should
move away from the animals so the other
animals doesn't know see the definition
of humane is to show compassion or
benevolence so how do we compassionately
a hill now
a reason city before they I believe
there is a blender and necessary needs
not absolutely necessary it's a block
away it's the race or another glamour
right like for example you need software
example you need some solutions have you
need to implement violence just to bring
peace okay so the thing is in that
aspect we have to the police for example
they would use their buttons or wherever
over the country they will use rubber
bullets and if you will say oh hey it's
not a real so then you need turn so I'm
like this whole thing Bob you know
kumbaya and you know like you know he
stirs it brings him you killed animal
was never knows if the thing the fear is
this yeah okay number one you should
stretch in animal here so for example to
sit there fo yeah
firstly that's what we are told to
sharpen the knife yeah cover the animals
eyes yeah okay and do it as fast as
possible if they do not feel pain yeah
so you know if you you know chocolate
veins yeah one of them is going to block
that before sorry
have you ever blacked out before yeah
there's actually there's a recent study
that says that vegans are more likely to
have
we don't know the pain here is this I'm
not gonna use that against you and I
don't think to use that what having me
it wouldn't be fair about him to come to
a balance yeah that's that's it I got a
talk in front of you yes I get my power
I see this knife is very sharp
yes and I try and slip the dog's throat
what's worse the purpose it gives me
pleasure
well you're crazy taste pleasure none
it's crazy taste but you're crazy I
could taste them I'll call the police
let's go get a police officer [ __ ] this
man
why do people eat meat it's the taste
touch it no no there's a range of
reasons we have to survive that's not
why we're thinking about you do be
affirmed that for example our ancestors
yeah yeah it was an easy like a apple
and shove it okay so what that means is
now you're saying that in today's age we
don't need it
yes that's subjective that our ancestors
did need a cleaner to survive so you
wouldn't be here today if you didn't eat
meat
yes okay I've also wouldn't be here
moving wait for the whip wait baked
women I wouldn't be here but you can you
can even Bridget even you can have
children without a this will have great
people I wouldn't be here without right
how do you know they're right because
what you mean how do I know my son is
married who's very moving back thousands
and thousands and thousand eligos and
that marries like a relationship married
why they have to be raped no but my
point is just assuming it happened in
the past that doesn't make it ethical
today and you can tense
I know you can find a context right
where where would be ethical ancestors
needed uses five so therefore a
receptacle and that doesn't make it
ethical in this context in the same
sense killing another human can be
justified in some contexts in
self-defense violence can be justified
that doesn't justify it in the context
where I don't need to okay but the thing
is you're giving an extreme example
you're talking about rape I'm talking
about in general maybe they've got
married and a variety of other reasons
yeah okay so the thing is no I'm saying
that should have meat it's it's not an
absolute luck no no no Wilson was a Jew
you have to be it to be a Muslim you
have to Amy but the issue is to condemn
somebody that eats me or to see them as
Barbara Garcia that's one possess it it
has to be a fine balance I've never I'm
not condemning you yeah well you also
about my walk you're religious no I'm an
atheist I'm not saying you're a bad
person for so so so look you know there
are some recent studies also show that
France have
like they can sense pain as well there's
no research there's no evidence
employees can feel pain there is there
is there is some but there is some
evidence towards it this that would you
agree that they are living there living
okay so then the point that comes to is
this year there's an item currently
leasing or gonna be that look for
example the tomato or for example you
don't know if let's say argument's sake
if science finds out right but these
tomatoes or these things actually feel
pain what does one do sure because then
it's going to come back to and necessity
of okay I can understand that imagine if
that was the case yeah you would you
might say you cannot see you might say
you know what will we eat the tomorrow
well words if you paid okay when you cut
in the middle okay we'll try to do it
this way so it's less painful
so as Muslims we say we implement the
same thing as what we see as some kind
of the necessity not absolutely and
simply doing procedures in place so the
animal you know eating it it's let's say
you're right let's say though all the
plants are sentient beings they feel
pain they want to live the thing is the
animals we eat we are feeding with
plants so there are more plant deaths
because we eat the animals so we'd
actually be using far less plants if you
went vegan now okay okay good very very
good point but the issue with my point
is this is that to me we live in a
system where there's rules yeah yeah so
if those those are in place I can say
you know what me maybe I'm stepping on
some kind of living particles here let
me know move yeah yeah do nothing then
the reality check keeps in and then we
need to say to ourself okay look we can
combat animal country or say let's join
forces yeah
what the air when I'll have been in what
taco come together against ranches yeah
now with this we can define about you
know are we coming together against
oppression yes to us animals we can come
and join forces for that but why is our
purpose to no one listen the harm to us
animals being hit he'll start disgusting
behavior
no see that's different you know that
the example shows so I think though you
think was your name Chuck Jack do you
think the first step there we should
take is this animals are going to be
sorted to be eaten what's gonna happen
yeah it's what it's gonna I know it's
going to happen I think we should come
back animal cruelty because this is
firstly the first one we can argue with
there we can debate with a necessity bar
like we define cruelty can you define
that I personally if you ask me I would
say being arched being harsh to any
living being unnecessarily because how
it includes stopping them in the throat
for a necessary reason another something
is different to cutting okay cutting the
reasons starving is there okay Georgie
how do you use cut no no no you fifty
because the whole point behind it we
have a method of doing here
the animal is removed knowledge does
they don't want to they don't want to
see it this piece you accept this in
human contacts know why because why do I
need to call him before
you may because you like the way they
test animals allow ways of killing
animals right but there isn't a halal
way of killing clods right because what
why is that okay so so for example we
haven't been told that but even for us
we are told that even when you go to war
do not harm trees you know that some
trees yeah and the Prophet said I sent
him said in one of his hadith the signs
of that day of judgment the signs of the
end of the world visit purposes he said
that even if it's the day of judgement
if you are planting a plant carry on
dominar finish so it's important to do
something for society but we haven't
been told directly for example the how
you treat animals except I mean plants
we have that respect
of course of course that without even
tired animals because obviously consume
and consume see and they should it is no
or when we tell that they have some kind
of feelings or emotions we don't know
yet and you've already acknowledged the
fact though the alamos we have further
facts so you must use the reality and
you brought the partner it could be
hurting Alamosa features all time
without nor ears within what do I do for
the difference here is incense so if you
accidentally walk around inside that's
different always to nervously sense also
but then what you need to do is then
then does that mean
kill the animals and the plants like
because David was killing me because you
said like animals
I want to eat more vegetables so that
quality the quality must murder no I
don't believe that that's nonsense if
they did but then that wouldn't be fair
for me to come and say let's let's all
sheeps more so they don't want they
don't kill they don't well you know it
makes sense to stop reading the shapes
but then do it nobody chose you to get
rid of them stop reading them yeah look
there if we do that you see the reality
exam I understand where you're coming
from
don't get me wrong I understand we're
uniform you seem like someone that's
caring yeah you've come here you've done
this why because you care for the
animals we care for the animals as well
what is then can we have a middle ground
can we have a middle understanding well
let's start with stop includes its
animals be in the sports analysis or be
in general because then once we come to
obstacle then that means there's a less
animal suffering and then we'll talk
about humane ways because we're gonna
stop them at least answer them I will
tell you how let's return it because
they because it's a find amount the more
we buy the more they creates but that's
insane as human beings with greedy
people
but you're not gonna stop your impact
you can leave it's there never exploit
animals again by picking up vegan
sausages are often Pig sausages Rigsby
yeah amazing video
is absolutely amazing yes yeah so why
would we exploit animals where we have a
clear alternative no it comes back to
reality these people that is good I wish
you need smaller justify the behavior
I'd sing out I'm not a hundred percent
but then again I don't believe that
given in the main way I believe it
doesn't hurt I believe if you shop in at
night and do as much as possible
obviously think the same thing could be
said for human if I do a very short line
say for example if for example if I put
you in each organ with a joke oh yeah
yeah and then after a certain amount i
black out why because the blood doesn't
go to the brain so it's enough for me to
say slit someone's throat why you seeing
this well for what goodness because I
like the way they taste
no no no I get my chicken Islam there's
no other reason you get kind of busy I'm
saying that's brighter option however in
the clutches of your indicate yeah
you're gonna die that's how the concepts
read I know and I'm saying like if I was
gonna kill someone now so I killed some
of your friends he's way different to
them and I said I use a sharp knife they
didn't feel a thing
yeah what about make you know has he
taken a human life I know no reason but
just a taste
well you could say taste but what's the
problem so I like the way they taste us
the reason I'm doing it
yes so again so I just live the way they
taste NFL eat them okay I would say it's
legitimate because a human and animal
isn't the same okay then what's the
difference that that justifies that
differences even even real yeah yes he
has faculties that and animals which
faculties these animals have families as
well etcetera but were not intelligent
there's a lot of do you think we should
assign moral value based on it
intelligence so if you're intelligent of
me yeah
should you eat this admin so what if
you're more intelligent of me should you
be treated better than me whatever I'm
seeing as human beings we are not the
same as animals of course a Korean
agency must be able to cure a human
being I want to say it's the same as
killing an animal you don't need to you
don't need to value the the animal to
the same value as human and all the not
to enslave them you just need to believe
that the animal is worth more than your
taste pleasure no it's not about to
taste it's about survival it's not
because no cushion by do you admit that
you could leave here today and be vegan
so it's not survival but it can be look
at you for you know it depends how am I
going to get that for example normally
can I afford it shock waves on the rafts
are you telling me to live can I can I
live by it you can say yeah these people
factors but I don't know that okay yeah
sure yeah yeah so if you think about
price the cheapest food and seed market
rice beans lentils vegetables so vegan
vegan is quite expensive no no they
can't be Eva doesn't have to be yeah
exactly so what I'm saying is that
there's a whole commitment behind it
yeah but what I'm saying is that it goes
back to again
it's number from one extreme to another
and that's telling you that you have to
be to be able to be me in this last
because my my choice being a vegan as a
victim or as yours does someone's dying
I can I can say that for example if I
open up a do some research I believe
that you're killing more puns to me I
buy consume no no the animals are eating
is killing more plants
so then it goes back to what every
animal they're only there because we're
beating them no no I know but even if
you didn't beat them they still need to
survive no because we're breeding the
new diversity is their survival is this
a matter of the sheep the cow is there
severity across Yemen up there to show
to take that away from where you do take
that away from them
no no but if you do yeah that's
oppression to them you do do that you
take it away from when you kill them
after trying to say it's just it's a
cycle if you take them away then what
they're eating because they're killing
vegetables then those tiny little
killing then why are you quite a
vegetable we just stopped being them we
stopped reading billions of them every
year none okay then that means you're
ending life based on Isis hopes rising
tonight
you're doing they're doing the same for
us and we want to survive we want to eat
the greatest thing is not the survival
we are organizing it so you're doing the
same with us then then terminate all
human beings yeah because if if
vegetables have or rods have emotions
and feelings were all dead
we call it nothing there's no evidence
that they have emotional okay if they do
Chuck that means we need to get rid of
the Sheep - the Sheep market in the
vegetables we can't leave them because
you know we can't eat enough
what happened let's say we found out
those words ah this is we found all the
plants our feelings they love their
families all the stuff what we do is we
kill the least amount possible we stop
reading animals
I need a plans directly no no that's
again you still the point comes to you
don't want to hurt anyone now you're
going against your place with the lesser
of two evils that's the scenario where
we have to choose lesser of two evils
they examine its overrides a scenario
that I know but Jack you see this is
where the survival kicks in in your life
okay what's the best thing to do yeah so
I'm saying let's come together the best
thing to do is to stop animal cruelty
because please bidding killing them okay
I'm seeing right now breeding and
killing them in that harsh terrible way
is not the same as treating them in a
dignified manner yes in a dignified
manner when it comes to the slaughter it
is that minimal time of one minute or
less say argument's sake they feel pain
then twitching them throughout their
life putting them in cages the lesser of
two evils
I need you to come together is to work
on that so you got three options
otherwise we're dead you see that he
never you're dead economies very few
options about given terrible lives in
cages torture them and then kill them
then we've got the the way we kill them
after happy lives
no they live a happy and quickly and
then at the moment of small talk we said
if our children just the way just the
way if we learn that the vegetables and
plants have feelings that we're gonna
have to sacrifice the say okay that
science is what's the faster way for us
to do this so they don't feel pain okay
get them from the newts torture but
that's our second option the third
option is just leave them alone that was
all die we all die
vegetables and plants have feelings yeah
we're all finished the Nuba okay well
they they don't well let's say they take
did I say it did not increase which so
shouldn't read animals who died we want
obviously the spirit of animals then we
are plants yes then we can't have them
we're gonna harm them then we alternate
there'll be a necessity
okay then can we agree then for example
if there is a certain necessity in India
to have animals can we have them it can
we justify them suggesting of course
cannibalism can be just okay so what you
see is extravagance no I'm saying that
there is absolutely no necessity the
American Dietetic Association largest
organization of nutrition experts the
world 2016 they said it's a vegan diet
healthy for all stages of life being
healthy I respect that but the thing is
that for us if there is a necessity to
eat meats then you could just fire can
do you agree they're justified I also
believe yes and I also believe that you
can just violence the humans of this
ancestor okay
so you're against I think what we're
against it's right because even the
Prophet peace be upon it you wouldn't
have read yeah every day is it's
actually this customer yeah very
exploits it yeah
so I feel I'm with you on that yet that
the exploitation the level or the level
that we're at which one yeah so that we
need to do is that whoever necessitates
is should that should be done yeah
so if I was to show you that there was
no necessity to achieving animos at all
you see you don't have to do that
because it has to be studies yes it has
to be what do I have to do so for
example I've tried a vegetarian diet and
like sometimes I'll just put out really
weak
yeah both train is well and even though
I know there's some vegan trainers his
wife seem like they're quite intentional
oh yeah okay but the thing is even with
them some of them feed the cats me yep
obviously but the point where I'm saying
but what I'm saying is is that look will
be a question for me to Cohen the force
my way of life other people can reduce
you because you're nothing its qualities
you don't have to get in the way today
yeah you should have the processor so we
can limit it to a certain amount and
work our way down to snow and animal
cruelty but the thing is with forcing
like for signals to do things we should
force you to do certain things or
certain things I guess the better way of
putting it is force people not to do
certain things so he forced people not
to murder we try to force people try to
force people to abuse children yes we
try to force people not to abuse dogs or
kill dogs
I think we should also extend up
chickens pigs cows and force people not
to exploit and kill them as well yes we
should force to minimize unnecessary
killing of animals there we go so we
agree yes so
so as soon as the solution is aligned
then it's unnecessary to animals you
agree that it becomes a moral obligation
to be vegan
look I as a Muslim can't say that but as
a Muslim I won't say that somebody's
committed Haram for eating meat yeah I
can't say that you don't need to be a
you said you said it we should you said
no he showed us subjects if so quickly
as Muslims have meat is better for you
to have me so very some of the
properties people said to us that there
is disease in red meat yeah so Josie's
gonna read me yeah so the poster said
only all kinda from dates and honey and
all other kind of stuff here and then we
need to talk about the factors that the
harms that this may have to the beasts
we're gonna get behind so there's such a
messy issue you see you don't see well
that means to me know what this one's
hanging then after we'll you said which
you don't need kill out of most of which
is necessary yes
so that's subjects we don't know when
these two figures we say okay so one two
hundred million animals should be killed
not to free be it or zero if it's not
necessary nor us that's nice to have you
sure but if so if you were to establish
you can live healthy for the rest of
your life as a vegan yeah you do it I
will do it by what's possible as a
Muslim I don't need to my my my
hopefully insurance and paradises and I
hate a lot it's not even me really hard
yes even even good know why he provides
haven't seen any evidence for it okay
should we talk about that I might come
back late after finish recording in so
far for the here this inane fundamental
thing it goes back to you know because I
didn't a we're talking about being cruel
to animals
yeah we call me created that code is
most powerful yeah that we need to
understand that as much as we care about
the animals
their emotions etc we need to
acknowledge that obviously if there's a
high intelligence that he has rights as
well and that we should try our best to
obey his laws as watery and translate
does anybody popular caring about the
ants and everyone else but the one who
created the heavens and earth of that
blessedness very short talk two cards in
this one of the most beautiful
conversations I hear there's some the
health information on their right I'll
come back in a week and you'll be vegan
and you can do interviews and the listen
I try to cut down mean sometimes it's
not healthy trust is helping you to me
it is as you can see Brazilian beautiful
discussions here in the park vegans
vegetarians me personally I'm a
flexitarian yes